that's the scary thing about insights
uh you look like andrew wiles working on
the firm oz last theorem
is you don't know something seems like a
good idea
and you have that idea and it feels like
this is a leap
like a totally new way to see it but you
have no idea if it's
at all useful uh even if you think it's
correct you have no idea if this is like
going to go down a path that's
completely counterproductive
or not productive at all that's that's
that's the crappy thing about invention
is um
like i have i'm sure you do i have a lot
of really good ideas every single day
but like and then i'll i'll go inside my
head along them
along that little trajectory but it
could be just a total waste
and it's that i that you know what that
feels like it just feels like
patience is required not to get excited
any one thing
so i think this is interesting because
you you raised andrew biles he spent
seven years
attacking the same thing yeah right and
and so i think that what attracts
professional researchers to this is
because
even though it's very painful that you
keep fighting with something
when you finally find the right insights
and string them together
it feels really good so well there's
also like
short term it feels good to
to uh whether it's real or not
to pretend like you've solved something
in the sense like you have an insight
and there's a sense like this might be
the insight that solves it
so at least for me i just enjoy
that rush of positivity even though i
know statistically speaking is probably
going to be a dead end
i'm the same way i'm the same way in
fact that's how i know whether
i might want to keep thinking about this
general problem it's like if i still see
that i'm getting some insights
i'm not at a dead end yet but that's
also where i learned something from my
phd advisor actually he was a
real big inspiration on my life his name
is benny sudekov in fact he grew up in
the former soviet union
excellent he was from georgia but he
he's an incredible person but um one
thing i learned was
choose the problems to work on that
might
matter if you sub if you succeed because
that's why for example we dug into
coping it was just
well suppose we succeed in finding some
interesting insight here
well it actually matters then it's
worthwhile
yeah and i think covid uh the the way
you're approaching
uh kovid has two interesting
possibilities one it might help with the
culvert or another pandemic but two
i mean just this whole network
theory space you might unlock
some deep understanding about the
interaction with human beings that might
have
nothing to do with the pandemic there's
a there's a space of possible impacts
that may be direct or indirect
and the same thing is like with andrew
wiles's proof i don't
understand but apparently the pieces of
it
are really impactful for for
mathematics even if the main theorem is
not
so along the way the the insights you
have
might be really powerful for
unexpected reasons so i like what you
said this is something that i learned
from another
friend of mine who's also he's a very
famous researcher all these people are
more famous than i am
his name is jacob fox he's jacob fox at
stanford also a very big inspiration for
me we were both grad students together
at the same time
well most importantly you're good at
selecting good friends ah yeah well
that's
that's that's the key you gotta find
good people to learn things from yeah
but his thing was
he often said you know if you solve a
math problem and have this math proof
math problem for him is like a proof
right so suppose you came up with this
proof
he always asks what have we learned from
this that we could potentially use for
something else
it's not just did you solve the problem
that was supposed to be famous
it was and is there something new in the
course of solving this
that you had to invent that we could now
use as a tool elsewhere
you